يوم الاحد على ملعب
تنطلق الصافره للمره الاخيره في مونديال
قطر 20 22 النهائي يجمع بين الارجنتين
وفرنسا المنتخبان يطاردان النجمه الثالثه
اخر بطوله حققتها الارجنتين كانت منذ 36
عاما ورفعها الاسطوره الراحله مارادونا
بينما فرنسا توجد في نسخه الماضيه هي رابع
مواجهه تجمع الفريقين في بطوله كاس العالم
المره الاولى كانت في اول نسخه عام
1930 الاخيره في مونديال روسيا الماضي
وتحديدا في دور ال 16 انتهت المباراه
وقتها بفوز فرنسا باربعه اهداف مقابل
ثلاثه وكانت احد امتع مباريات البطوله
ميسي لا يزال يمني النفس باللقب الاغلى
وقد قاربت مسيرته على الانتهاء بينما بابك
نجم فرنسا يسعى للتتويج بالكاس المره
الثانيه على التوالي قبل عيد مي الرابع
والعشرين فبينم بابي ومسي سباق اخر على
الحذاء الذهبي في البطوله حيث كلا النجمين
يملكان خمسه اهداف في تلك الوسخه
[موسيقى]